you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is the game
between Harry Nelson pillsbury playing
on the white end and Emmanuel asker this
was played in 1896 in Germany at the
Nuremberg Tournament Alaska at the time
was world champion Pillsbury the
following year would become a United
States Champion and that would be a
title he'd hold on to until his passing
in 1906
so Pillsbury's light in the chess world
is one that shined extremely bright but
just not for too long is all he could
very well have become world champion so
let's see what it is about this game
that earned Pillsbury a brilliancy prize
the Somerville Massachusetts native
kicks off with e4 Alaska replying with
the French defense we have what
variation of the French steinitz
grabbing some Kings side space typical
undermining of the white center what is
not typical the game move D takes C
common nowadays Universal move Knight to
f3 interesting follow-up though
connected with D take C what is that
exactly after Knight c6 a3
okay so white is looking to grab some
Queen side space and one might also
reason secure the bishop post on d3 from
any Knight attack what would be very
logical here is to develop a piece and
recapture a white could fall within
queen g4 and Knight f3 the game move
Knight takes d4 Knight back Bishop d3
these two moves appear on the surface to
be interchangeable but I like this
decision first 'if I've is a great
strength and black would like to
undermine it but cannot the Queen's eyes
are opened to the h5 square white
doesn't have that
if the night is on f3 the game follows
with queenside play black really wants
access to c5 and we'll get that there's
too much fire on B form this cannot be
maintained and white certainly does not
want this rook brought to life so gives
the knight a shove back home Knight f3
knight c6 ight space but it's not
without its drawbacks
c5 C 4 C 3 a4 a3 all holes all gaps in
White's house or I've seen me on the
Queen side of the board and sure enough
what we will see are many of the black
pieces making use of these squares
making use of the squares where white is
weak following up a Bishop to e3 another
developing move and preventing any d4
ideas maybe to d7 castles black is
preventing an f5 pawn break Knight to e2
so this move 14 white is already looking
to reposition some where is this Knight
looking to go next it's a bit of a
mystery one would think Knight to d4 but
yeah not the case let's see what White's
idea is Bishop e7 Queen e1 Knight b6
the other night is occupying deform
Bishop d7 Queen f2 so there's a threat
here White has now a battery along this
diagonal and is looking to unmask the
Bishop and queen with some Knight takes
c6 ideas white side steps this tactic by
playing Knight to a4
just to highlight the tactic if the rook
moves we would have Knight takes c6 and
let's say after pawn takes we take the
knight
so you don't have that tactic anymore if
the night is on a four c5 is now secure
enough
following up we have Rick on a 2 b1
this is preventing the Knights both
Knights from focusing on d3 that can be
a bit uncomfortable for white if both
Knights are observing the d3 square so
rook a to be one clearly interferes with
Knight to be two but this is also an
important middle game a moment you know
middle games are one of the most
difficult points in a game phases of the
game you know what plan to come up with
one may be thinking at this stage as
white to play g4 and then f5 crashing
through with f5 and getting at that
black King but
g4 is played this is keep in mind this
would be a highly committal move by
white f5 is in but hang on whose king is
the more vulnerable still a mystery
so g4
is not played rook a to be one this this
pawn stays put on g2 this will be the
White King shelter after rook a to be 1
h5 so there we go forget about any ideas
of g4 black is interfering with that
idea
pillsbury now plays on the queenside
some more this pond now has some great
depth playing into b6 and the b v square
is now open for many of the white pieces
in the night is one who may look to jump
in there next and who knows what his
ideas will be from that point c7 and d6
look extremely appealing the game of
Knight takes bishop
note that if this Knight captures the
pawn we have these tactics in mind as I
already pointed out so Knight takes
bishop
Vaughn takes and black picks up a pawn
on a3 so what's the idea from here can't
play g4 enough five who needs g4 that's
what Pillsbury says f5 anyway guess
where this night on e 2 is going and G
takes f 5 night to F form these are two
wonderful posts for the Knights ok white
just pitched upon in order to grant this
knight access to the f4 square there's a
lot of different ideas here connected
with capturing an f5 d v e6 by one of
the Knights the game follows with h4
this is not best one of the better moves
is to put the bishop on a more secure
square like B form h4 is grabbing a
little bit of kingside space it's also
taking away possibly some ideas of coin
g3 and maybe sneaking in along the Kings
side not so easy for the Queen to do
that now of course but now comes this
beautiful combination that is you know
making use of the Queen side of the
board the center the king side it's all
connected
RUP to a-1
Bishop's it he drops back to e7 and now
we have rook takes Knight giving up the
exchange in order to lure the bishop
away from its defense of e6000
Knight takes pawn let's just pause for a
moment light is down a full rook
but this king is extremely vulnerable in
this night you can't put a value on him
he's currently striking at the Queen
possibly looking to jump into c7 it's
extremely dangerous for black hair to
say the least
Lasker sees it best at this stage to
actually give up the Queen the gay move
is Bishop to d7 and then we have a
knight takes Queen but I'd like to touch
on one of the variations this at this
stage it's important why not let's say
try to save the queen
what would follow is Queen takes f5
White's threatening a million won in
multiple ways Queen c6 could then be met
with Bishop g5 if Bishop takes Bishop
game over with Queen to f7 taking it out
just a few more moves Queen b6 d4 and
let's say the move Queen b4 is played
this would run into a check a capture
and then we would have a very nice
sequence here where eventually white
will be winning the Queen and soon the
game it's reading a mate and six it's
very dangerous for team black to say the
least
Lasker saw this position and thought you
know the best resistance is to actually
give up the Queen try to maybe come up
with some type of fortress but there
will be no fortress this is just a
beautiful combination on the Queen side
and now in the center here and what an
enormous night he ends up picking up the
Queen and the following moves in this
endgame sequence are not particularly
instructive but let's see how the the
game follows getting some trades in a
good strategy at this point is to get
rid of one of the rooks that makes the
coordination a bit more difficult for
black and this Queen
is an absolute animal
but white king is going to be playing
here
a very active role the a pons picked up
and yeah the queen is just always
striking wherever black is weakest loose
pieces and we have some passed pawns
over here eventually black will be
throwing in the towel here the King is a
fighting piece the white king and soon
all of these pieces will actually fall
exclude me all the black pawns will fall
Queen to d6 if this is actually the last
move of the game Lasker resigns at this
point this pawn is following and soon
this pond will be falling next King g8
you could actually play this first and
then pick up the pawn with check and
yeah this is just way too much for black
to deal with but this is as far as I
went in this game again the endgame not
particularly interesting but certainly
that beautiful middle game combination
sacrificing on a for luring the bishop
away and then smashing through on the e6
square that night repositioning to the
f4 square + the f5 advance was a really
really nice idea doing without this
weakening of the Kings side g4 pitching
upon and yeah feel free as usual to
share your thoughts on this one I
thought it was a beautiful sequence and
hopefully you did as well that's all for
this video feel free to leave any
feedback in the comment section below
and I'll catch you in the next one
that's all for now take care bye